0% chance that's gonna happen this is a
surreal I can't imagine the show look
exactly the same
I know fans are asking you this all the
time probably crew members production
everybody asking you what is the status
of Bachelorette because it was more than
three weeks ago now that you guys went
on a two-week hiatus what discussions
are you having we're all chomping in a
bit to get back to work just like
everybody else does and as soon as it's
safe enough for all of us to get out of
our homes then we can even start the
conversation of how do you produce a
television show and one thing people
also realize is the moment we can start
getting back to work that's just when we
get back to work we don't all of a
sudden have a television show we have to
get Claire and the guys and the
producers and the camera and actually
produce a show go shoot it and then
produce it what is the situation with
casting for Claire's season and the guys
who we had do we still have all those
guys well firstly I do want to emphasize
we are casting for the next Bachelorette
that is Claire and the next Bachelor we
don't know who that is yet but yes if
you have somebody you want to nominate
somebody or whatever go to abc.com size
casting and nominate somebody for the
Bachelorette or the bats were still
looking and the reason we are doing that
is to your question are all these guys
still available we don't know are they
all gonna be healthy enough are they all
gonna be available our job is gonna be
on the line if they leave I mean all of
our lives turned upside down so it's
naive to think that all of these guys
are just gonna be able to come back and
kick right back up where we left off my
guess is there is 0% chance that's gonna
happen and that sounds so scary and
vague to say that the schedules for
these huge temple ABC show coops are
changing how do you feel about the
literal scheduling changes of when these
shows could air if we can get out of
quarantine if we can get back to
production we as the bachelor family
have the ability to actually do that
rather quickly
and establish our shows shoot shows and
give them ramped up a lot faster we're
able to a little bit have a closed
campus maybe quarantine a little bit
make ours a little safer then say you
know these these shows that shoot in
Hollywood people are coming and going
and it's impossible
kind of socially distanced yourself so
you know in a weird way I think we may
be the first to be able to get back and
do this again I'm speaking as if I know
how this is gonna turn out and so it's
it's assuming this thing will trend down
this summer we can ease these
restrictions hopefully get back at some
sort of production though so do you see
that when filming gets going again
you guys just lean into and acknowledge
that some things about the way you feel
may have changed that this whole thing
happened I can't imagine the show look
exactly the same this is gonna be one of
those times that yeah Claire season will
probably be a little different you'll
probably see them discussing who we
quarantine with what were you doing you
know did you did you god forbid lose
anybody those conversations are gonna
happen and again the thought that all
those people were unaffected by this is
very slim considering the percentages
and so yeah it's gonna look a little
different me I mean who knows maybe
Claire is like little taking people's
temperatures they come in two days I
don't know but it's gonna be it will be
a brave new world and I think as a
reality show you embrace that and you
just roll with what comes - well a lot
of people have said this I also don't
know how in what world clear as it
googled Instagram stalked all the family
members anyway they were all in house I
would've yeah
so I think you do you see look if you
keep some of those guys you just have to
lean into that she knew a little bit
about them before this all began that's
kind of the interesting thing and again
leaning into these things and embracing
it what if she says hey you know Michael
are you know I was looking I saw that
you you know loved dogs or it could be
something like oh I saw you had a
girlfriend whatever you like knows what
what things might come out of this
bachelorettes do you see this as a bit
of a silver lining in that you guys can
really get the best possible guys for
Claire you have more time what we're
going to do is regroup and make it the
best we possibly can when we get to ship
and if that allows us to get guys you
know better suited for Claire
you know more age-appropriate whatever
it is we're gonna do we will do we
always do our best by giving more time
have you guys talked about what might
happen with Bachelorette and paradise
because paradise usually starts in June
right so see have you discussed if this
keeps getting pushed back is their world
pre-shoot paradise before Bachelorette
from my understanding from the
executives from Mike Tyson everybody
else our priority is bachelor
so there's no way in the world that this
season of bachelor would just get
scrapped I mean in this quarantine time
I'm never gonna say never do anything
again
so all we're thinking about now is okay
we need you know because the thing is
you kind of need the backs rep to round
out the casting to get into paradise
that's kind of how this thing rotates
and so our priority is Claire ax rent
then let's see again if things don't go
as planned with this virus and in this
quarantine maybe we won't have time to
do it all would you prioritize
Bachelorette over VIP if you had to make
that choice I always say this in every
interview people say what's your
favorite shows bachelor and bachelorette
that is the franchise dad that is our
baby that's what started this thing 18
years ago and it may sound silly to be
loyal to an inanimate object but I'm
with this franchise I'm a little too
those shots the bachelor/bachelorette
are what makes our world go around
everything else comes off so yeah I
think it's it's important a couple more
questions about the other shows because
the fans want it all a lot of potential
new shows have been thrown out for this
year a summer games was talked about a
spinoff from winter games a senior
citizen level show what is happening to
those two amidst all this well
bachelor Summer Games was scheduled for
production I believe May after
Bachelorette we would have gone and
quickly done Summer Games and then got
into the back from paradise that's
obviously like the Summer Olympics
itself is is off the table obviously we
can't do it
for a lot of reasons paramount or you
know top of that list is you need
international members from the bachelor
world to come in to the United States
that's not possible
you know we had people in from Asia
Europe all over they can't get here so
there's just no
do it we can't do it all be assumed
election and the senior citizen I don't
even know me honestly luckily that was
so early in production and in the
incubation period I know that we were
going to probably do it but my guess is
we're gonna put a pin in that my niece
was tweeting about some stuff was he
implying that a big announcement was
coming which he has done before what we
see is what's gonna happen so I've been
talking to Mike if not every day every
other day Rob mills @av Steve we've all
been you know we've all been
brainstorming we want this to be as
positive as we can be so we're all just
throwing everything against the wall
when we get back and everything's
contingent on when enough of us can get
back maybe I can get into a studio
safely and we zoom with people couldn't
we shoot a high light type of special
where we we go back and look back at the
great episodes maybe the great seasons
and backs look that's right history and
we talk about those and we have special
guests maybe we zoom or shanked them
that kind of stuff how are the
behind-the-scenes people the crew and
production were so used to being on the
road and working so hard and being
together as that bachelor family and now
everybody's spread apart it's affecting
everybody so holiday I'm just telling
you actually the other day you know at
this point in the quarantine I would
have we my bachelor family would have
been in four or five different cities
three or four different countries
we'd be somewhere around the world right
now you and I would be missing each
other yes but no so that that is you
know the bizarre thing of how all of our
worlds have been dumped upside down we'd
love to make the show as much as
everybody loves to watch it we like
making it we love doing what we do it's
it's crushing us right now we know this
too shall pass and there are bigger
problems and bigger fish to fry but yeah
we really wish we were making an
incredible show with Claire I mean I was
thinking the other night I'm like we'd
be over halfway done baby and Claire
might be narrowing down finding the love
of her life like how exciting and I hate
that that is stolen from her in this
particular time
[Music]